[Music]
in real-life superhero news and LU
submitted by muchacho Cacho
character Tom Hardy helps catch a
runaway mope thief
oh don't worry I'm opening this TV leave
straight tackle the [ __ ] what
happened was early two teenagers about
16 years old oh that's nothing I thought
it was like a crazy guy he just beat up
some kids yeah it could have been a
crazy 16 year old though okay okay go on
some 16 year olds I'm going to use easy
but I'd like me say like oh yeah man
this guy tried to rob me I beat his ass
really tell me the details
she was his 9 year old man and he had
this butter knife and Angele very nice
[ __ ] injury I just [ __ ] kicked
them into dentures and it flew out it's
like just not a hero story maybe he was
ex-special forces dude what were warned
or some [ __ ] [ __ ] he's [ __ ] killing
machines he 90 doesn't take me 8090 his
bones are like ashes this room yes there
was these two teenagers they had stolen
his moped and they were running a red
light and that's when they hit a
Mercedes and when they hit the Mercedes
they just fled the scene just drop the
mopeds are running away yeah well
shouldn't that's when Tom Hardy got out
of his Mercedes no he was walking down
the sidewalk same outfit Bobby dope and
then that son he thought this all
happened and he just started sprinting
towards the that's high cuz the other
one went the other way as us sprinting
he went through like these Gardens he
was vaulting over walls [ __ ] yeah I was
it was like an intense scene witnesses
said like it was crazy in his own stunts
and stuff like how witnesses were
following through the fences like so
yeah it was tardiness yes I'm finally he
caught the the team and then so he
grabbed him by the neck and started
patting him down for any concealed
weapon and then at that point that's
when
the cops arrived and they were able to
arrest that teenager and they also
caught the other teenagers so is a
hit-and-run or what am I taking anymore
no their mopeds so they just dangerous
all the mopeds and then they hit and run
yeah exactly
so Tom Hardy just saw hit and run and he
was like not today basically pretty much
right yeah I was that and so uh
apparently a witness said that once he
caught him that he proudly announced I
caught the [ __ ]
what do they put in his coffee in the
morning London yeah I said I'm not wrong
[ __ ] would you be ready to just [ __ ]
chase a guy through a neighborhood at
any moment not if it wasn't a personal
attack yeah thank you it must somebody
[ __ ] was a hit-and-run and I saw that
I was like that's dude I hope you got
insurance but if you had a triple shot
espresso then maybe right I'd be like yo
mopeds are really [ __ ] fast I'm not
that fast
yeah God but I would have been like 16
year-olds are really fast I'm not that
fast yeah
sprightly unless he was up in character
for this new movies working on yeah I've
done the mindset of a superhero for
three and then maybe I can see why he's
running in a suit this is a chase that
happens we started [ __ ] with all of this
each got a point where he'd be the best
I don't know whether all the targets
that are along the way I think they're
just showing the path of where they ran
that car core yeah so when a witness
asked like what happened because he had
rent like through his garden so that's
one time right he was like the little
[ __ ] nicked something and now he's got
himself a broken leg
oh I'm heartbroken I want to beat up a
16 year old the team that got in the
accident
oh okay well nedra moped and he ran I
know that's not running on a broken leg
or as soon as they get broken when Tom
Horn son I don't know told you with our
officers two teams it could have been
the other team that got caught and then
the other one didn't get a break
someone's like I would have been funny
and totally discredit Tom Hardy because
it's like bro how far did a guy with a
broken leg yeah really far Tom he's like
yeah sorry I could do a three minute I
can do a 30 minute mile is like max you
think if Nick I didn't break his leg a
30 minute yeah you're gonna be I hope he
wasn't wearing flip-flops that day which
one
Tom party yeah no exactly I'd be the
[ __ ] wear pajamas and flip-flops
that's like my daily wear I'm just tough
he what he got away today
industry in the world I'm not running
with the with these flip-flops no way
officer do I get some kind of metal for
reporting this incident am I here oh
yeah get me an article written about you
right now telling apparently has folks
a spokeswoman declined to comment that
is pretty crazy though it for actor like
a holic big Hollywood actor a
multi-millionaire and you get involved
and like I guess like these petty
affairs it's pretty great you it is I
think that means he's a hero because
like he's still in character part of his
community man he just trying to be part
of the community yeah to set up a future
political run it was all [ __ ] ruse so
I thought - I think it's like what Tom
Hardy up to a new movie coming out maybe
and Tran from Muslim sham bad publicity
Scott guess what the 16 year old was
actually just an actor paid to do dish
doesn't welcome person to kind a comment
but you wrote [ __ ] ten articles about
them mmm-hmm the two teens are in police
custody ISM but they're going to get
paid and the lawyers gonna get them all
and the police are going to get paid is
that part of it to you don't I get any
credit I got no I think he's a great
hero
catching a sixteen-year-old kissing
heroes are fast and have a lot of energy
and he beat the [ __ ] out of them that is
my dream I am kind of jealous where'd
you get the fact that you beat him up
[ __ ] God by the throat you [ __ ] I
want to grab somebody no don't call
McCartney then yeah I mean unnecessary
you know it's like if you could catch
criminals but you don't have to really
disrespect them it's like cops like that
unnecessary things that they do when
they pull out a gun freeze you [ __ ]
[ __ ] like dude why you got to do like
the personal info yes what does that
have to do with anything getting
directly call him a [ __ ] she was telling
a witness it cost a little car well I
guess that's different that's like
talking [ __ ] behind his back you know
what yeah it's like oh hey you guys know
ya Joseph was an [ __ ] it's like I'm
not talking to you Joe yeah sorry I'm
hung over here but I guess it makes it
better I guess yeah meeting ground by
the neck I mean the throat we found in
my neck it's not the same thing now like
this gruff stage called it yes I took
them up like a baby kidnap scruff to
kitten interesting because I mean I'm
okay with the whole violence against
criminals but I'm not okay with hurting
their feelings like the system you
talked about Ilana the emotional scars
take longer to use because someone's
robbing a bank
doesn't make it okay to call him a
[ __ ] right all you got to do is
shoot
that's it why do I the extra words
you're making it too personal that has
nothing to do with you so you just got
to prevent the crime that's all it is
but maybe it's sort of disarming in a
way like emotionally that hands up your
small dick [ __ ] hey that's mean
and also that I didn't know you were
going to say it I had to get me had to
like do their job today more because
you'd robbed the bank so is kind of
personal because like I had to get for
my death today do this they can get you
through your [ __ ] I could have
been at my desk sorting paperwork by any
random girl does make these flowers man
she's I feel like they got it all wrong
because what they're supposed to say is
thank you for letting me keep my job
[ __ ] right because they're
providing they're providing me just this
was the I remember the very popular
thought theory in middle school where
you would throw trash on the ground and
then you'd be like creating jobs for the
janitor new people like that we all new
kids oh no no actually I mean Walter
because I thought was kind of funny but
I would clean now Patrick's not like
that kid wears like it's very jail
chancy yeah that happened I'm gonna go
but you do that at home too yeah yeah I
clean up after Maya after my bit yeah
one time the janitor was kind of talking
to himself in the bathroom and then she
was like guys and then like I hear him
wiping the toilet and he's like you guys
do this at home yeah oh [ __ ] all over
the freakin [ __ ] all over totally the
same thing I'm like do you got [ __ ] on
your toilet see at home and that's not I
always wondered who those kids were you
could look at a high school janitor
space and for every wrinkle they have
it's like it's like pouring a tree like
they got [ __ ] stories do it
probably most [ __ ] up story you could
hear about ever vomit eyes yeah drawings
of the bathroom
oh yeah like where they find like a dead
baby prom night kind of [ __ ] and they
got to clean it up to go sailing yeah
half of all time dude everyone mine
every every problem I read every may I
read at least one story you'll see next
month Winter Formal out a chick who gave
birth in the bathroom and just
you know proms don't happen at the
school they happen at like a hotel or
something like the janitor wins so still
whether janitor at a hotel with [ __ ]
up prom kids foreskin
okay well that's not the same guy oh man
well you know kudos to Tom for like
chasing that dude down because chicken
Tony is really tiring because when we
did it for Bart's birthday like oh my
god you don't so many fences it was
ridiculous what the more obstacles that
I see I go I'm tired I get even more
tired the more fantasy job so yeah I
just kept buying him for the whole day
there's like a birthday pricing yeah the
whole know I had video on it let's go
and if he caught on and he thought it
saying sucked it I don't want to go out
I hope he caught on yeah I didn't so we
caught him at his house we were all
waiting next to the door and injeel was
trying to get him to come outside and I
think as soon as he got out he jumped
over the fence into the neighbor's
backyard jumped another fake thank you
our course technically ran like he was
in a car chase we just got out of the
car though yeah anyway you're saying
that you're behind him with a book and
pie you know I say we go this way over
there we go it not worth it Oh people in
every corner way the puppy we talked a
few and then we're like it's just too
hard once you give a kid a pie and I'm a
big kid it's like oh there goes birds
like to the wrong circle had a fight
slingshot pulling it back and launching
those things rate the neighbor's yard
without you catch on how many positives
you taking free card in the morning I
just went to go work out as soon as I
came out of the gym I got pie right in
the face and I was running around I got
pied and then later on when I went home
and go take a shower okay I think I
think they got me then I think they got
me for my birthday I'm cool and then
we're just hanging on the house and then
my dog started like acting really crazy
and I'm like wait they smell people
outside right now
nautical [ __ ] I'm gonna get tied again
so as soon as I went outside I
immediately jumped a wall that try to
avoid them for this was funny okay and
they did a Python they tied me here I
thought you were going to say so my dog
jumped in my lap and then he popped me
in their face like
a trainer for weeks how's it going guys
don't forget to like the video because
if you don't I will break your [ __ ]
legs thank you so much for the last
video don't forget to click right here
or I'll break your [ __ ] arms click
right here guys